i am so happy that we are still here
with the incredible
john cena
thank you so much for being who you are
um uh it's
man i just wish everybody would be it's
tough it's tough it's tough well
any advice you know as a
a parting word for
people to have the bravery to be
themselves because we all have to find
it even sometimes every day
yeah uh
everybody everybody is is uh
especially nowadays in in the
realm of social sharing and motivation
everybody's uh
pretty quick to like share quotes and
and things and
um i specifically use twitter as a forum
almost like a journal of philosophy for
me
um but there's a reason i publish
those quotes instead of keep them to
myself
and that's to hold myself accountable
because i want to be the person i tell
people that i am
so when i put something out to the
universe that
instigates a conversation about
philosophy or
tackles an uncomfortable subject
it makes me accountable
when i tell you i love my wife it makes
me accountable she knows i love her she
doesn't need me to tell you but it makes
me accountable
and i think that's important for me as a
system of checks and balances for the
rest of the world to keep me in line
and i just think nowadays um
we have the freedom of speech
but we don't have
any accountability a lot of times for
that
so
people can tell people there
a certain way and don't necessarily have
to walk that talk
and that's that's hard business because
you have to
you have to choose values
you have to choose beliefs
you have to define purpose and you have
to to be honest with yourself on who you
are and all of that stuff
is hard work yeah and
i guess my advice is it's not easy
because we all want to we all want
people to see us as
perfect folks just remember that
everybody's flawed and we all
we all make mistakes uh
but
it's hard it's hard work but uh
damn it's worth it
[Applause]
i think the world of you please give my
absolute love to your wife
i don't even know
how to end this other than to say thank
you because these are the kind of
conversations that i could only hope to
have
on a show like this and it takes you to
have them so
john cena his show peacemaker is now
streaming only
on hbo mac it's incredible
[Music]